bonjour mona alors pouvez vous nous en
dire plus sur cette prolongation un gros
coup dur pour la majorité qui voulait
justement prolonger cet état d'urgence
jusqu'au 16 février au prochain c'est
une victoire presque inespérée pour
l'opposition qui remontaient contre le
gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois déjà
et qui en a tout simplement profité hier
pour faire passer ce projet de loi car
les députés de la majorité n'étaient pas
assez nombreux lors de ce vote
c'est donc une décision qui aurait pu
être évitée si la majorité avaient été
plus présente à l'assemblée nationale
pour info l état d'urgence permet donc
de limiter les déplacements ou de
confiner est la population un vote qui a
provoqué la colère d'olivier ferrand le
ministre la santé écoutez je suis rentré
dans deux chambres dans ce service de
réanimation de corbeil-essonnes dans la
première chambre il y avait un jeune
homme de 28 ans de 28 ans en coma intubé
et ventilé avec pas loin de 10 pouces
seringue au pouvoir à la fois
l'alimenter lui fournir les médicaments
essentiels pour le maintenir en pis dans
la deuxième chambre
il y avait un homme en surpoids âgé de
35 ans c'est ça la réalité mesdames et
messieurs les députés voulaient valentin
certains lycées elle est là la réalité
deux hôpitaux
elle est là la réalité des hôpitaux
c'est à la réalité nombre d'hôpitaux
vous êtes en train de débattre de sujets
alors que nous soyons se bat pour sauver
des vies de cette manière-là dans nos
hôpitaux
vous l'avez entendu olivier ferrand
comme on ne l'avait jamais vu ce vote il
a été motivé pour certains pour par
cette volonté le besoin surtout de se
retrouver et de célébrer lé fêtes de fin
d'année comme l'a précisé cette débuté à
l'est républicain écouter les fêtes de
fin d'année sont un moment privilégié
il convient de tout mettre en oeuvre
pour permettre aux français de se
retrouver en famille noël se fera dans
tous les cas de figure a de son côté le
gouvernement est bien à le moyen de
revenir sur ce vote avant la danse on
l'adoption définitive de ce projet de
loi
vendredi le gouvernement pourrait
également demander une nouvelle aide
délibération ou tout simplement
présenter un recours de son côté olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé est
attendue dès aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale à partir de 16h30 il sera
auditionné par la commission denquête
qu'ovide 19 dans le cadre de la la
mission d'information concernant la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
mona à merci à beaucoup pour toutes ces
précisions